hi I'm Erik Bosse the Avengers in-game
trailer may be pretty secretive with
details and possibly using old footage
tweaked with the effects but one detail
I think that we can trust is Hawkeye he
wasn't in Avengers infinity war and now
he and his gnarly haircut are all over
this new footage now sure I guess this
could be a prank by the directors and I
actually plan to remove Jeremy Renner
from another movie but I think the
Hawkeye footage is the stuff that we
should be paying closer attention to and
a new detail was discovered from the
recent in-game trailer something you
could only see in the 3d version and you
thought I was joking about having to
cross my eyes at trailers to be able to
catch all this stuff like it's magic eye
art I see boobs it's always boobs I'm
gonna break down this new easter egg and
more importantly what it could mean for
the end game story it's more the way in
the case my theories are accidentally
right in the runer like okay in this
trailer there's a shot of Hawkeye
running in a tunnel as a big fiery
explosion tears through it and this
looks like the same tunnel he showed up
in in the first trailer but people who
saw a 3d version of this trailer
something that I didn't know existed and
I don't know how you find it but in this
version in that explosion behind Hawkeye
you can see the bodies of what looked
like a couple of outriders the
multi-armed foot soldiers at Thanos and
the Black Order used to invade Wakanda
in Infinity Ward it is interesting that
the outriders would come back for
endgame because as far as we could tell
they served their purpose in infinity
war they attacked Wakanda and kept the
Avengers busy enough to leave vision
undefended disrupting their plan for
sheree to safely extract the mine stone
and for Scarlet Witch to destroy it
allowing Thanos to get his hands on it
so why are the outriders back and ingame
and what does Hawkeye doing with them I
see three possibilities first Hawkeye
could simply be clearing out the
remaining outriders left on earth I
blown them all to hell in the Marvel
Comics the outriders are more complex
beings genetically engineered spies
soldiers capable of reading people's
minds by sinking their fingers into
their temples but in the movie they're
mostly soulless drones like orcs waves
of Goro's mindlessly kind of causing
themselves and everything even Thanos
his past army that Chitauri had guns is
idiots can even be trusted with swords
the Black Order even made it clear how
little value they place on their lives
Thanos would have nothing but dust
and blood we have blood to spare ouch
próxima even if they're genetically
engineered they're standing right there
so when the four members of the Black
Order all die and Thanos departs earth
what happens to the rest of the
outriders the wakandans the Avengers had
beaten a lot of them and a number of the
outriders actually dusted and Thanos to
snap but there were probably some
remaining outriders and they were
probably stuck on earth with no master
to serve kind of like wall-e enter Clint
Barton the trailer showed him on his
home farm with this family and you can
see the ankle bracelet that Scott Lang
also had to wear under his house arrest
following their decision to aid and abet
fugitives in civil war but something
tragic will probably happen to this
idyllic tableau I'm predicting his whole
family dusts because every other time we
see Barton in this footage he looks
pissed
destruct one Metallica track away from a
perfect Frank Castle presence so Hawkeye
might make it his mission in the opening
act of endgame to hunt down and
exterminate any remaining out riders
left on earth
like maybe they cluster in underground
tunnels like this one in Hawkeye in his
grief kills them all like Anakin
Skywalker massacring Tusken Raiders
they're like animals and I slaughtered
them like animals as much as I'd love
that there might be a more practical aim
for Hawkeye's anti outrider rage like a
second attack against Thanos I have
speculated in the past that the first
act of endgame could feature some rushed
payback attempt against Thanos by some
of the more Trigger abullah vengers cap
Black Widow Thor rocket maybe Hawkeye -
if Thanos is still using outriders for
protection Hawkeye could be trying to
infiltrate Thanos his defenses and
crippling them or if we assume that
timeline Medlin is part of this plot
this tunnel could be in some other
timeline or back in time when Thanos was
still in the early stages of assembly in
his army and Hawkeye and the other
Avengers are trying to disable this
invasion force before it can get to
earth then again how instrumental were
the outriders to Thanos his victory
really sure they were effective at
distracting the Avengers and
complicating their goal to destroy the
mine stone before Thanos could get it
but really once they anos got the time
stone would anything have stopped them
from completing the set I'm just saying
if the Avengers find a way to change
that
I'm lined like butterfly effect' disrupt
Thanos's victory path targeting his
mindless foot soldiers isn't a very good
tactical move compared to say trying to
force a fumble with one of the Infinity
stones so assuming a fight between
Hawkeye and outriders isn't a smart use
of Hawkeye's energy maybe there's
another explanation like he's the one
being attacked
looking at other shots from the end
GameTrailers it appears that there will
be some conflicts set at Avengers HQ
there's a shot of Ant Man and war
machine suiting up another shot of Ant
Man as some fiery light fills a room and
another shot of Ant Man shrunken down on
a desk behind him in those other shots
pole-vaulting with a pencil as fire can
be seen behind him one explanation is
that Thanos could target the Avengers on
their home turf as they start to make
progress in their strategy to undo his
actions the outriders could be useful in
that assault just as they were in their
invasion of what Conda the tunnel that
Hawkeye is in could be a subterranean
drainage or electrical tunnel the
earlier shot looks like that tunnel
leads down from a hole in the ground
perhaps the outriders are trying to use
this as a way to infiltrate the Avengers
base like an alien's the way the
Xenomorphs uses the vents in the ceiling
to sneak past the marines defenses this
would set up a potentially frightening
scene with Hawkeye alone in the dark
trying to clear these beasts before they
breach the base ending as all great
action sequences should with an
explosion maybe one that collapses and
blocks this tunnel off do you think
Hawkeye is hunting these outriders or
defending against them comment down
below with your thoughts follow me on
instagram and twitter at EA boss and if
you happen to live in the LA area come
check out my live comedy show darkest
timeline comedy this Friday April 5th
and every first Friday of the month
it'll be me Maude Garrett Sam bashful
Melina Tommy Beck told the funniest
nerds I know all in a super reference
variety show
Acme theatre North Hollywood ticket info
in the description below thanks for
watching and let's close that with some
more Hawkeye Anakin I don't like sand
it's coarse rough and irritating and it
gets everywhere it only gets better
[Music]